it was an ordinary friday in may 2017
for the uk's national health service gps
across the country
were working through their daily lists
of patients ambulances were responding
to call-outs
and hospitals were treating the most
sick
then suddenly an emergency of a
different kind struck
nhs computer screens started turning red
and displaying the message oops your
files have been encrypted
along with the image of a padlock there
was also an
instruction to pay a 300 ransom to
recover those files
or else they'd be destroyed
the nhs declared a major incident as
fears grew that this could be the moment
an attack in cyberspace
caused death in the real world
in the end that didn't happen but the
wannacry attack
is still the gravest known cyber
emergency
suffered by the uk to date impacting
thousands of patients
and it could have been much worse had it
not been for a 22 year old hacker
called marcus hutchins who disabled the
virus from his bedroom
in his parents house in devon it kind of
felt surreal at first because it was not
how
difficult you'd expect stopping an
attack like this to be
i was like wow that was that was a
little too easy
while the nhs was the highest profile
victim
the wannacry attack impacted more than
200 000 computers
across 150 countries around the world
the uk and the us has since blamed a
group of north korean hackers
states criminals and terrorists all use
cyber to attack each other in the gray
zone
it puts anyone with a computer in the
firing line
but also means that anyone who
understands computers
has the ability to fight back the most
sophisticated malware
can be designed to cause large-scale
physical harm
think a cyber pearl harbor or a cyber
911
with mass casualties and devastation
that hasn't happened yet
but the wannacry attack shows that this
threat
from the gray zone is real
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor at sky
news and you're listening to my podcast
into the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare i'll explain the covert tactics
used by states criminals and terrorist
groups
to deceive gain influence and at times
kill
in this episode we look at the growing
threat to real life from cyberspace
and what the uk is doing about it
i also talked to marcus hutchins about
the part he played
in stopping the wannacry cyber attack
[Music]
cyber threat takes about three forms
really
kieran martin set up and ran an
organization tasked with responding to
cyber attacks in the uk
the national cyber security centre or
ncsc for short
is a public facing part of the country's
top secret intelligence agency
gchq one is essentially about
theft and that could be very simple
theft
it could be theft of money but it could
be theft of more complicated things like
um intellectual property increasingly
it's about theft of
data sometimes that can be
strategically important and that takes
you into a set
the second category of of cyber attacks
which is essentially about strategic
advantage and disadvantage using it
outside of anything
close to war or armed conflict to gain
some sort of advantage so here's an
example of data theft that's a strategic
disadvantage in
2015 the us confirmed that the chinese
state had walked off with the federal
government's
database of prospective and current
employees and the security clearance
forms
let me just step in here to elaborate
because this is a big deal
especially given the state of relations
today between the us
and china in 2015 it emerged
that a suspected chinese cyber hack of
the us
office of personnel management succeeded
in stealing
personal data on more than 20 million
federal government link workers
including the fingerprints of more than
5 million people
that means beijing could have a database
that would flag up
potential u.s intelligence officers
making it harder for them to work
against
china though the chinese government has
always denied the hacking allegation
the uk learned a lot from that case i
think there was a we weren't certainly
thinking that that could never happen in
the uk there was very much a sort of
there but for the grace of god and
that's the sort of thing that you know
countries like here and allies are are
having to look very carefully at
i guess also there must be a
counter-espionage concern too because it
means that anyone going to china who's
on that list suddenly becomes
of more interest perhaps exactly and you
know going beyond that i think
spying is for centuries has been
opportunistic and
you've mentioned a very significant area
where that sort of data set would be
useful but also it is more generally
useful in terms of understanding
you know the way in which bits of the
state where you've got the data from
how it works who's who and and so on so
that's why you see
you're going beyond that particular case
that's why you see attacks on
that sort of data set all over the all
over the world really
the second category of cyber threat
listed by kieran
also includes the secret planting of
computer viruses
on another country's critical national
infrastructure
things like power stations or
communication cables or airports
these intrusions can be for spying or
for giving the attacker
the ability to cause trouble in the
future
what we call a cyber trade pre-position
to gain a leverage so that if there is a
tension between country
and country b country a's got some
implants down on country b's essential
systems and can and can utilize that so
that's the second part is strategic
competition if you like but short of
anything like
conflict so cyber theft cyber advantage
and then there is cyber destruction and
then the third part takes you into
the more the area of actual harm
the one thing that hasn't happened yet
despite all the speculation and warnings
over 20 to 30 years is some sort of
cyber catastrophe
various u.s defense secretaries have
warned of cyber pearl harbors we haven't
come close to that yet and actually
attacking deliberately a computer system
to cause
physical harm to lots of people's really
quite hard and not many people can do it
and thankfully
those who can do it tend to be rational
and therefore don't do it lightly
so some of the terrorist groups for
example who we know have nihilist
tendencies and would love to and sadly
would love to kill hundreds and
thousands of people cannot
do it by a cyberman but we can see
is um large-scale disruption disruption
of public services commercial activity
that can be done by states sometimes
accidentally as we saw with
a russian attack in ukraine in 2017 that
spread
into western companies he's talking
about not petia
which is one of the world's most
devastating cyber attacks to date
russian hackers are suspected of
unleashing the malware against ukraine
in june 2017 but it went viral and
spread across the planet
encrypting and destroying data on all
infected computers
the kremlin has denied involvement
unintended victims
ranged from the shipping giant mask in
denmark to a chocolate factory in
tasmania
the total financial cost from the attack
is thought to have been more than 10
billion
it was masquerading as ransomware but it
was actually disruptive it was supposed
to
effectively degrade the systems and do
commercial
damage it wasn't designed to hurt
anybody and it didn't hurt anybody it
was designed to inflict
economic pain like i find it really hard
to understand how
like a bit of malware or a bit of cyber
could
cause significant death like how would
does it happen
how could how could that happen what
sort of things would have to be hit for
that to happen
in 2015 it is widely believed that a
russian state attack on the city of
kiev's electricity supply
put the city into darkness depending on
where you were for between one and six
hours
at various parts particularly in the
winter with no
eating you may if that went on for a
prolonged period of time
you might find some people in harms in
in harm's way
there are concerns although as i say
resilience
should be a real part of the story but
there are always concerns about
industrial control systems
um as they're called our scada systems
what are they um well basically they're
controlling mind of a blast furnace for
example so can you can you just can you
hack into the computer controls for
blast furnace and set it on fire killing
anybody who's near it that sort of thing
so that's the sort of way in which
people have speculated about it in the
past
could you have the complete shutdown of
military systems for example
and so on and then you know again
hollywood hasn't helped us here if you
go back all the way to 1984 and war
games
where you know a teenager in a book i
think it's chicago isn't it hacks into
the pentagon and starts launching
nuclear missiles
i mean when you step back and think
about it that really shouldn't be
possible and so far as i know it isn't
and it wasn't it wasn't one of the die
hards as well and they thought it wasn't
that quite more realistic when they had
like
like a computer hacker that like turned
off all the traffic light systems and
things
yeah so i think there are things um uh i
i mustn't have seen that particular i
think i lost count after die hard three
um might mean four there are
possibilities like that
think about all the technology used in
daily life from
smartphones tablets and watches to smart
cars televisions
and even for some smart fridges a cyber
attack
on any of these items could have real
world consequences
for whoever's using them
in fact the opportunity to cause harm
with cyber weapons
is so great that the cyber world is now
an
entire war fighting domain in its own
right
alongside land sea air and space the
cyber domain is really a new and very
much invisible domain
for for conflict maricha shaka is policy
director
at stanford university's cyber policy
center
and a dutch former member of the
european parliament
and i think what makes the the digital
realm
or cyberspace as some people call it so
uh
relevant today is that on the one hand
more and more people rely
on digital connections and also in in
infrastructure and in industry and with
the internet of things
um the the internet is really in in ever
more places
and that means that the potential attack
space for those who want to do harm is
increasing
and so any vulnerability any
human weakness any lack of proper
safeguards and protections can be
exploited
and on the other hand we see that the
legal frameworks that we know
for example the threshold of an act of
war
or other kinds of accountability
mechanisms or or
you know legal provisions that can help
deter
bad actors or ensure accountability
after an attack
are lagging behind and so it gives a lot
of
space for people who want to do harm
they could be
state actors non-state actors criminals
terrorist groups or
intelligence services to stay just below
the known
thresholds for example of an act of war
and and
operating this in this very gray zone
where they know or they anticipate that
they'll never
face consequences for for what they do
and i think
uh that in and of itself the lack of
accountability there
erodes trust in our governments because
you know we can read about data breaches
or
hacks and attacks almost every day but
we hardly ever read about who is held to
count after attacking a hospital or
holding ransom university
or um eavesdropping or hacking human
rights defenders so
this is a very very serious problem that
needs to be tackled and and the gray
zone i think has to be closed so the
accountability gap has to be closed
i mean people talk about the the threat
of um and it's very cliche and i know
it's been said for a long time of a
cyber 911.
could you just explain like what what
would that look like
well i i hope we can avoid something of
the magnitude of 9 11. but
on the other hand there's quite a bit
that's happening already maybe more in a
drip drip fashion
where um infrastructure is attacked or
elections are being manipulated i think
looking for a one massive or cyber pearl
harbor as people call it
one massive event to change the course
of history
may actually be missing the point that
there's already so many
uh smaller events happening that that
really should be
should be stopped and so uh i hope that
we will not see
something you know of of the paralyzing
of let's say the electricity grid or
the um definitive manipulation of
elections
or the shutting down of critical
services like hospitals or or media or
something of that caliber but it's all
possible
it's all possible because essentially
connectivity
can mean vulnerability if there's not
the proper cyber security
and checks and balances in place all
countries have to be able to defend
themselves in cyberspace
supported by their militaries their
security services
and a huge and growing private cyber
industry
some states too possess serious cyber
offensive capabilities
these include the united states the
united kingdom
israel china russia iran and north korea
it's an area that's shrouded in secrecy
and rarely if ever avowed
take for example the stuxnet attack on
iran
it first became public knowledge in 2010
u.s and israeli hackers are thought to
have used a cyber attack
to destroy computers involved in uranium
enrichment
at a time when the world feared the
imminent development
of iranian nuclear weapons i'm not going
to speculate about who what when where
but just as a piece of code it was very
very sophisticated
so it avoided some of the perils of
other cyber weapons i mean cyber weapons
are called viruses for a reason
you know they're launched and they look
for something they mutate
they infect all the things unlike human
viruses you know they do have a
initially at least they have a
commanding mind but once they're
released
you know they can go places that you
don't intend them to go to they can be
caught and reverse engineered by other
people and
and released further where stuxnet was
very clever
was it was designed to do a very
specific thing which was to find a
particular type of i think siemens bit
of hardware
and if it didn't quite find it it would
stop after three attempts and just die
even then there is evidence that stocks
now
infected and affected a bunch of you
know tens of thousands of machines in
indonesia which last time i checked
wasn't a major protagonist in the
iranian nuclear program
uh tensions so you can see the risks
there with these things you know they
are viruses
they're not like conventional weapons in
that respect
when they're launched you have to take
great care that you know what you're
doing
to give a sense of the scale of hostile
activity going on
in the cyber dimension of the gray zone
the national cyber security centre
defended the uk from more than 700 cyber
attacks
in the year to august 2020 roughly about
half of these
are attributed to hostile states and the
other half to criminals
who are the biggest state threats who
are the ones that are the main actors
the top two hostile actors from the
point of view of a country like the uk
are china and russia but you lump them
all together as if you know it's sort of
chas and dave it's not they're
completely different actors
russia is projecting an area in which
it's strong from a general position of
strategic
weakness but it's good at cyber so it
uses it to its advantage and it uses it
to play in the great power space so it
uses it for classical
you know traditional statecraft motives
espionage strategic advantage
disinformation and so on and so it's
used as a method of projecting you know
what's left of russian state power
an example of this is a massive cyber
hacking campaign
against the united states that was first
discovered in december 2020
u.s officials have blamed russia for
what they say could be the most serious
ever
cyber breach of u.s government systems
it's still being investigated
then there's the alleged cyber threat
from china china the origins of china's
cyber
capabilities are economic in the first
decade of this century
a huge sort of ecosystem of chinese
cyber attack built up that was basically
designed to advance china's economic
expansion through
getting commercial advantage whether
that was through espionage so it was
through stealing somebody else's design
of a car whatever it was
it of course still spied um on
governments and that sort of thing but
that was basically the way the chinese
cyber attack system
worked it's conceptually quite simple
just they're trying to attack us and our
job is to try and make sure that
it does as little harm as possible
moscow and beijing
both deny allegations that they're
behind hostile cyber activity
cyber attacks have caused huge economic
damage but so far
no confirmed avoidable deaths there was
a case in the german city of dusseldorf
in september 2020
when a hospital under a ransomware
attack
was unable to admit a woman suffering a
life-threatening illness
instead her ambulance had to travel to a
second hospital delaying her treatment
she died but it's not clear whether she
would have died anyway
making it hard to say for sure that her
death was caused by the cyber attack
the potential for patient deaths on a
massive scale
is the fear that raced through kieran's
mind on the 12th of may
2017 when he received a call to say a
cyber attack
had disrupted services at several uk
hospitals
right now the safest way to bank is from
home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills
you can speak to a mortgage advisor by
video or over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
wannacry was a very simple bit of
ransomware that caused chaos
harold thimblebee is a professor of
computer science at swansea university
he gave evidence to a parliamentary
committee that looked into the wannacry
attack if we
back up to why it happened microsoft
developed software that's called xp
which nobody uses anymore
but it has ended up being used in all
sorts of things like mri scanners
and blood systems and all sorts of
things
and basically people lost track of it
and microsoft stopped supporting it
but the national security agency in
america discovered a backdoor
into xp and unfortunately hackers got
hold of
that eternal blue as it's called
vulnerability in xp professor thimblebee
is referring to a hacking tool
called eternal blue that was developed
by the u.s spy agency the nsa
but a hacking group called shadow
brokers leaked eternal blue online
in april 2017 in what's been described
as one of the most destructive nsa
breaches in history
the identity of the leakers has never
been revealed
but their action gave hackers around the
world a u.s
made cyber exploit to play with and it
probably ended up in north korea where
probably the north korean state
developed wannacry to exploit
this bug in windows xp and a few minutes
later
lots of people were suffering from
wannacry on their old xp systems
that's the gist of it can you give a
sense of like how it
what it what happened in real time from
the moment they kind of did their bug
and unleashed it
to when actually there was like a real
real time
impact okay so somebody would
switch on their computer and a
red screen would come up and say you've
got wannacry
and if you want to have your data back
send us some money
it's what's called ransomware so it was
encrypting
all the data on the computer so the
computer was basically useless
but saying send us some money and we
will
give you the key to get your data back
and what was the effect of that
on you know on on the public on real
life in real life
lots of computer systems well old
computers old
xp systems stopped working and the nhs
was one of the main uses of old xp
systems
like if you buy a cyclotron or mri
scanner it's run by a computer
and i guess the nhs leaves these
computers running and it all seems fine
but it's still got flaws in it because
they haven't kept it up to date
it costs money to keep software up to
date so you're saving money and it seems
to work fine
and unfortunately the hackers broke in
for kieran martin from the national
cyber security center
the first he heard about the attack was
as he was heading home
at the end of the working week i was in
a train home on a friday afternoon
turned back um what did it look like
when he first started to see that there
was a problem
how what the technical people what do
they say well actually
you know the first thing is that it
unfolds kind of on twitter you know
so i think it was there was a regional
nhs
organization account which started
saying you know we're experiencing
difficulties
and then all our things in other
countries started to say the same thing
and then it was you know the incident
people picked it up when there's
something weird going on here
and then you know i ran senior officials
at the department of health and said
yeah we're starting to get stuff
at that moment computers at hospital
receptions and gp surgeries were
freezing
ambulances were having to be diverted
and mri machines could no longer perform
scans
there was this feeling of real fear
at the start about was this going to
impact patients
and given what we saw in dusseldorf the
other week
you can see why we felt that and
so that was the principal thing on the
friday afternoon
the nhs digital service sent out their
first alert that something was wrong
at 1 pm after receiving reports from
four
nhs trusts of ransomware attacks hitting
multiple nhs services
the number of trusts reporting problems
quadrupled over the next three hours
that was when nhs england declared a
major incident
i arrived back at the office after the
train i know we've got to brief the home
secretary at seven o'clock or whatever
it is you just have to make sure and
that forms a forcing function about
getting the information picture working
out what the comms options are
you know etc etc paul chitchester is the
director of operations
at the ncsc who we met in the previous
episode
as the day went on you started to get a
sense of just the scale and the enormity
of it as obviously people were reporting
in and
and hospital uh you know were being
disrupted
partly that was actually organizations
shutting their systems down as a
precautionary measure
not the wannacry ransomware sort of
having an impact so that was you know a
lot of disruption was done just by sort
of you know trying to sort of uh turn
things off and put them in a safe space
or safe state so that was kind of
through the friday uh we
uh at that point it was really trying to
get our hands on the actual malware and
get our hands on the tactical details
trying to understand what was going on
this was not just a uk
problem the wannacry virus was freezing
screens and demanding ransoms around the
world
with more than 200 000 computers
affected
in at least 150 countries
it's a ransomware worm which means it's
able to spread from
computer to computer without the need
for someone to click
on an infected link victims ranged from
universities in china
to the global delivery firm fedex and
the nissan car plant in sunderland
a message on people's computer screens
told them their files had been encrypted
and they must pay 300 rising to six
hundred dollars
to unlock the data official advice was
not to pay up
because that would be rewarding the
hackers
plus there's no guarantee your files
would then be restored
as the worm spread government cyber
experts around the world
including at gchq in the uk were trying
to work out how to stop it
simultaneously and without any official
instruction or coordination
individual hackers and cyber security
companies
were also logging onto their computers
to help
i think i had just got back from lunch
and i had noticed kind of a lot of
news about this um this attack going on
marcus hutchins
a self-taught hacker was taking a week
off from his work for an american cyber
security firm
it was early afternoon on the 12th of
may and the 22 year old was at home
in the seaside town of ilfracombe in
north devon where he lived with his
parents
yeah so um as as kind of a career-eye
track malware spread so this was
this was kind of right up my alley and
um i just saw it spreading and i thought
hey
like i'm not working today but this
looks like a big deal so i'm gonna i'm
gonna take a look at it
so i kind of just uh i got on the forums
i got on twitter
and i tried to find out as much
information as i could
before kind of diving into it myself
what does it mean like diving in like
i'm kind of having visions of
um of like the matrix is it kind of is
it kind of like that
can you just explain what it is what you
do so um
i basically i i get a uh a copy of the
malware or virus and then i um i reverse
engineer it to find out kind of
what it does like what the code is doing
uh try and get an idea of what its
intention is how it's spreading
and i i just try and build up a the best
picture i can
of what the malware does and so can you
just recall back to that day when you
were
when you were sort of you know trying to
investigate what was going on like what
were you seeing
what was happening so i i know there's a
lot of
outbound connections to um to the smb
service
which was strange for this kind of
malware and uh
what does that mean sorry oh okay yeah
so it was a
it was connecting to other networks like
uh the um
it was trying to remotely connect to
just random networks and it was going
through a list it wasn't
any kind of structure it was just kind
of picking a random ip address
connecting to it
and uh i kind of this is this was not
common for this kind of malware so when
i was digging into it i kind of realized
oh this is this is spreading computers a
computer this isn't
distributed by email or spam uh this is
actually spreading between computers and
so then what happened
um so then i also noticed it was
connecting out to domain which was not
registered
and uh this is something we often do for
our job is if we see
unregistered domains or any kind of uh
anything in the malwa that would allow
us to track the spread we will kind of
get in on that
so um i went and i registered this
domain so that i could see how many
computers were being infected how fast
it was spreading kind of what what
countries it's targeting
and um kind of found out a bit after
that that
the uh activation of the domain also was
uh
capable of killing the malware itself
and uh completely stopping the spread
for those who like me aren't
particularly technical
what this means is that marcus
inadvertently
found a kill switch for the ransomware
worm by registering the name of the
domain he mentioned
in order to have a better sense of the
scale of the attack marcus actually
managed to stop the virus from being
able to spread any further
and how did that feel when you realized
that um
it kind of it didn't feel real because
uh often like malware like this is
incredibly hard to stop and
it was uh it was not this kind of big
feat it was
just like just registering the domain
which we do like
on a daily basis hundreds of times was
enough to disable this threat so it's a
mix of
like wow we've we've stopped something
really big and also
that was way too easy how quickly did
you realize
the enormity of what you'd done um so as
soon as i realized i'd killed it i kind
of i knew how big of
a deal it was because uh obviously the
intention of raising the domain was to
track the spread so we actually knew how
fast it was spreading and how many
systems it was affecting already
so just kind of knowing that we had
stopped it was already a big deal
this all happened that friday afternoon
as the rest of the world of cyber
security
was also still scrambling to understand
the attack
it took time for everyone to realize the
impact of marcus's quick thinking
and even though the rate of new wannacry
infections started to drop
there was still huge numbers of infected
computers to grapple with
it made for a long tense friday night
saturday
and sunday for kieran paul the ncsc
and the top secret cyber team at gchq in
cheltenham
you know it was mayhem because i mean
even in terms of our capabilities at the
time
it was very early on in the ncsc's life
while kieran was an overall charge and
responsible
for briefing ministers in the public
paul was focused on stopping the attack
fixing the damage and finding out who
was responsible
certainly through saturday we we felt
this wasn't a normal
cyber criminal attack and then as we
built up you know over their sort of
following 48 hours we you know we're in
a fortunate position to be able to
pull different parts of that
intelligence jigsaw together
and so we were pretty confident very
early on of of kind of what was going on
there were suspicions took us months to
prove it was suspicions that it was
north korean
because it wore some similarities to
some attacks they've been doing in banks
across the world um in previous months
but because it was
ransomware people thought it was
criminal so but actually you know we
parked the whole attribution thing
because
frankly you know i don't think people
using the nhs cared whether it was the
north koreans or criminals who just
wanted to know when their appointment
would be rescheduled and whether they in
it and we wanted to work out what was
happening with nhs
um systems i think the key pivot point
for us was the monday morning
and what we really didn't know was um
so facts you learn when you do this job
that nothing to do with cyber
necessarily are you know over 1 million
people 1 million citizens turn up to an
nhs
point on a monday morning every monday
um and so
what we wanted to make sure was that
all of those citizens got the nhs care
they they were going to turn up for
and so that was a kind of key point and
actually when everything started to come
back online on the monday
we sort of started to to be more relaxed
and i think
the one that i've always said when i
talk about this is the amazing sort of
work that went on behind the scenes of
the nhs
and you know doctor surgeries and
hospitals
have actually sort of patching systems
and getting systems back up
over about 24 hours was absolutely
incredible
despite the quick response the cyber
attacks impact on the real world was
huge
in england it touched a third of nhs
trusts
and almost 1 in 10 gp surgeries
affecting almost 20 000 patients
the crisis took a week to resolve though
it took
much longer to update computer systems
and repair the damage
at a total cost of some 92 million
pounds
no nhs organization paid the ransom but
some other victims did
three months after the attack it was
reported that the hackers had withdrawn
more than a hundred thousand pounds in
bitcoin ransoms
from three online wallets they'd set up
to receive payments
all of this is a million miles away from
military strategy and military
capabilities and that's the big thing i
keep
thinking we need to remember you know
this is very much in the civilian
consumer space it's affecting real
people
and they're in in their ordinary lives
now the safest way to bank is from home
at lloyd's bank there's so much you can
do to manage your money online
from viewing statements to managing
direct debits to paying bills
you can speak to a mortgage advisor by
video or over the phone
and even pay in checks using our app if
you do need to visit most branches are
open 9 30 till 2 monday to friday
please wear a face covering and observe
social distancing to protect yourself
and our colleagues
lloyd's bank by your side terms and
conditions apply
on the 19th of december 2017 the uk
and the us accused north korea of
unleashing the wannacry attack
a year later the u.s justice department
charged a north korean man with alleged
involvement
in a series of cyber attacks including
wannacry
and also the hack against sony pictures
that we covered in episode three
pyongyang has strongly denied the
allegations
i asked marcus hutchins how stopping a
suspected north korean cyber attack had
changed his life
so i'd always been fairly anonymous i
didn't
really publish my real name or identity
because i like to just have
a pseudonym so
about a day after wannacry the media
actually found out who i was and
published my real name and my location
in the paper
so i kind of went from uh like my online
name was known but
my real identity was very unknown and i
went in a day from
being this kind of unknown name to my
my face and my my name and my location
is plastered all over the news across
the world
and how was that uh it was it was not
fun
yeah and were you uh were you living
with your parents at the time
yeah i was so what do they make did they
know that you were this kind of
tech tech genius i wouldn't say genius
but they
they knew i was into tech and they knew
i kind of worked in uh
in security they didn't know a lot about
what i did because i worked from home
so there was this kind of at first they
didn't even think i had a real job
because i was just in my bedroom on my
computer all day
naming and shaming the perpetrators of a
cyber attack
is a relatively new phenomenon uk spy
agencies
used to avoid identifying a particular
country
for fear of creating diplomatic
headaches or of giving away details of
an investigation
that could be useful to the attackers
that's always going to be a
consideration
but today attribution is increasingly
part of a nation's response to a
state-backed cyber attack
because it shines a real world spotlight
onto this murky area of the gray zone
seeking prosecutions is another way to
fight back
it's a u.s policy that began during
barack obama's time as president
even though the chances of ever bringing
say a foreign state hacker to trial are
minimal
so every cyber attack is a crime but
obviously you know we're not going to
see
chinese three pla officers in court or
russian intelligence officers
so there was a lot of skepticism when
the obama administration started to
publish indictments
about cyber attacks but it turned out
it was actually i mean it didn't cure
the whole problem but it was quite it
was quite useful
it was useful in several ways firstly
the americans used to complain to the
chinese and say right you're attacking
us and
because cyber attacks one of the
advantages of them for an attacker's
point of view is that they're they're
deniable
how do you know it's us and the chinese
state would say that to the americans
for years and they will show us the
evidence and for years the americans say
well we can't because it's classified
and then all of a sudden the americans
are saying well
here's a 26-page indictment from the
fourth district court of the state of
pennsylvania do you care to answer it
you know here's the evidence it was the
calling out matter
secondly and and you saw this with china
and to some extent
iran and and so on unless it was russia
indictments being a state-sponsored
estate tolerated hacker in some of these
countries is quite a good job
and if you're under indictment it means
you can't travel to the west
that's a big deal if you're an affluent
person and a non-western country you
might want to go to the united states
you can't because you've got the fbi
warrant on your head you can't go to
anywhere in the european union because
they've all got extradition arrangements
of the us so you know there is an impact
on that sort of thing so
is that kind of what the uk has done too
because obviously we've seen over the
last few years much more
attribution coordinated attribution of
attacks so i think the one thing the uk
hasn't figured out how to do yet um
i think it's just a matter of a
different legal system from the u.s is
how to do the
equivalent of indictments because the
um prosecution authorities work in a
different way so as far as i know we
haven't um
issued any sort of indictments or sorry
any prosecution orders against
an extra assad extradition against state
attackers but the other things about
using diplomatic pressure to call out
definitely and i think that's a good
thing the very creation
of the national cyber security centre
was part of the uk's efforts to combat
the growing gray zone threat from
cyberspace
the idea was conceived in around 2015
when david cameron was prime minister
there were basically two models
um and we tried to adapt the best of
both so model one was you do it out of
the deep state
you have a cover intelligence collection
capability and lots of very skilled
people
using powers that only the government
only specialist bits of government have
and you
find out what the russians are up to and
what the chinese are up to and
and so on but everything's classified
also point of knowing
that someone's been attacked by a state
actor if you can't tell the victim
or you can't do something about it so
model two that you have in some other
countries is sort of a very open
uh very civilian non-national security
organization that gives good advice and
so on
but the point is quite a lot of
commercial companies can do that some of
them are very big some
are very very good so what's the
government doing trying to compete with
with them and so we tried to put the two
together um
and that's what the ncsc was essentially
the ncsc
supports government departments and
deals with the public
from individuals to companies helping
them cope with cyber breaches
and raising awareness about cyber
security so it had the sort of top
secret
capabilities and people and powers but
it reversed the presumption of secrecy
we do need to keep some things we didn't
need to keep something secret and no
doubt after my time we still
we still do but the presumption was that
when you can
you tell people about a particular type
of threat um
you should kieran left government at the
end of august 2020
and is speaking to me from oxford
university where he now works
as a professor at the blavatnik school
of government
how do you see the cyber domain evolving
for me
the single biggest thing that i think we
need to do to develop it is
a bit like the general environment you
need to just improve it
you need to improve its health and its
security so
of course i'm not a cyber pacifist i
think we need to
retain sort of freedom to act when uh
necessary
but i just think countries like this one
all over europe
north america that sort of like-minded
open free societies we have far more to
lose from an insecure internet and
insecure digital environment
than we have to gain from it so the most
important thing we can do
as well as develop all these
capabilities the single most important
thing we can do
is just you know get some steps make
some effort to just
make technology safer because it's just
the same as improving the
the environment the air quality the
water quality you know it's like that
we are living every day in this
environment so let's
let's improve it let's make it a nicer
happier safer
easier to navigate safely place to
operate
but to improve this environment
it's important to understand the many
other ways
cyber can be used to cause and crucially
to prevent harm in fact the uk has
created a whole new cyber force
to better exploit cyber power
fleming the director of gchq and general
sir patrick sanders
commander of the military strategic
command reveal for the first time
new details about the only avowed
offensive cyber operation
launched by the uk it targeted the
terrorist group islamic state
in the gray zone of cyberspace and in
the war zones of iraq and syria
and i think it sends a sent a really
strong signal that
we and our allies were not going to
leave
uh cyberspace as an uncontested place
you know we we have to defend it uh we
have to make sure it's as secure as
possible
but that's next time as we continue into
the gray zone
[Music]
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from sophia
mcbride and michael greenfield
and narrated by me debra haynes
the head of sky news radio is dave
terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts